in 2018 there were over 16,000
vulnerabilities published in public
databases and that's just the ones we
know about but a program as simple as
add a cat to that couldn't possibly have
one of those right right you know what
stick around because we should probably
use cloud registry scanner to check on
our software supply chain just in case
add a cat to that is a very short
program no more than a dozen lines of
code implement its core functionality
but believe it or not it has hundreds of
dependencies each of which expands our
attack surface using other people's work
made out of cat - that easy to write but
it's also a potential weakness any one
of those libraries could be neglected or
compromised and with so many of them
it's next to impossible to manually keep
up with the ever-growing list of
vulnerabilities
what's the developer to do fortunately
we're using Google container registry to
store our container images it has a
feature that can help us secure our
supply chain caught vulnerability
scanning once we've enabled this feature
we can go back to our list of images and
look under the vulnerabilities column
and we can see that our tiny little
image has over 600 vulnerabilities and
only 38 fixes we could dive into each of
these vulnerabilities to see if we could
fix them for example let's click on one
of the image magic issues to find
details on exactly what the
vulnerability is an uninitialized
variable leading to memory corruption
now we could dig through the variables
use cases to see if this air is relevant
to us and even if there's not a fix we
might be able to set up some secondary
measures to protect ourselves but let's
try a different way looking through the
vulnerabilities list we noticed that a
lot of them are related to image magic
so let's reduce our attack surface by
swapping out image magic with the
simpler Python library caught pillo we
can also improve our security posture by
choosing a different base image we're
currently using Python 37 which contains
a lot of dependencies we don't need and
many of the vulnerabilities we're seeing
or coming from that image we can remove
most of them by switching to a slimmer
base image such as alpine linux and
since we're using alpine we'll have to
change our docker file to manually
include the specific libraries we need
but other than that the docker file is
pretty much the same we
just these two fixes we're down to zero
known vulnerabilities Google container
registries vulnerability scanning showed
us how to improve our security but those
changes came with the costs because we
switched from image magic to pillow the
app is slower and uses more memory than
before but for us this was a trade-off
we were willing to make eliminating over
600 bugs in a few minutes yeah that
seems like a win add a cat to that has
to be secure good thing we found out
about these issues before we had an
incident but I vaguely remember making a
last minute check in last night hmm I'm
Carter Morgan and in the next video
we'll use cloud security scanner to
check for any silly mistakes that might
have been introduced into the codebase
by someone I don't know who gremlins
[Music]
you